when we did purple rain at your at your
birthday i think it was probably the
closest thing i've ever had to that out
of body
like i knew i had the room and i knew
i was winning at the moment like in a
way did you i didn't
wanted to ask you that because oh yeah
you were killing it so much
i remember standing and i'm in the
middle of doing a radio show and i'm
trying to hold it together but
i said there's something [ __ ] going
on i don't think people
knew the level of guitar playing and
that it was like
you possessed the room and you knew it
you you felt it in that moment
you know it was a combination of so many
things it was wanting to impress
and and put on a show for you and then
it was also not wanting to let prince
down because people don't just cover
purple rain you're right and prince
hated when people covered his song when
he heard a cover he'd go uh
it's okay you know he wouldn't even even
even knowledge it yeah he hated it
well i'm very close with one of prince's
friends
i was like what do you say she's like he
he took a long pause
and then he said he's learning
he's learning
this purple rain thing i revisited a
million
[ __ ] times
[Music]
because when you're playing those leads
i go crazy
even when you're gracious enough to let
pat monahan come in and sing a little
bit
i love that moment i feel bad though
because i kind of stuck him with the
[ __ ] like
the triple lindy of the song like the
you know i kind of gave him the big
[ __ ] up moment that like i didn't want
to even deal with and you know because i
had too much to worry about with the
guitar
so i was like here you go pat is that
what you were thinking at that time
because i thought like it was just
gracious of you you were killing
and i was like wondering oh gee does
adam feel bad that he gave that moment
to pat like like
like like no no no no no i was happy to
do it
no i was happy to do it and i look i i
adore that guy he is
one of the nicest coolest dudes he's
great listen to this
that's you
[Music]
wow you nailed it man
you're learning you're learning